holy bunco's kids look out the keep it
moving tour is adding new dates
we're coming to a city near you
come and see us some stand-up and we
play ayg at the end of the show with the
crowd we answer your garbage questions
we've got some trash so far but i know i
know
there's deeper garbage out there around
the country oh yeah so come on out and
see us kippy tell them what they need to
know oh baby we're all over the place
tejas baby
uh september 21st will be in san antonio
texas september 22nd we'll be in houston
texas september 23rd through the 25th
austin texas for the moon tower comedy
festival and i ain't done yet august
26th will be at fort dallas fort worth
texas what then we're bringing it back
to long island baby what and all uh
september 30th and then we're coming
home the boys are the chickens are
coming home to roost baby
october 27th we're gonna be in
philadelphia pennsylvania and then back
down to tejas uh november 5th through
the 7th for skankfest south get those
tickets the link will be in the
description welcome to another exciting
edition of are you garbage the show
where you find out if your favorite
comedians are classy individuals or
absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley
let's go
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is are you garbage it's a little show we
sit down with your favorite comedians
and we find out if they grow up to be
classy or if they're just a big ol piece
of trash i'm your host holy coming at
you on a beautiful day we're down here
in auntie's basement she's upstairs
watching a little jeopardy yeah excited
for this new host mike richards yeah i
think he's out though gonna be a little
disappointed i told her she thinks it's
creamer
[Laughter]
my co-host is coming at you from across
the table this is a family episode just
the fam circle in the wagons a little
bit he is the ceo of ru garbage kind of
the head bozo around here so do me a
favor show him a little respect give it
up for my best pal mr kevin james ryan
hey [ __ ] what's up welcome to
ayg uh
this please make sure you rate view
subscribe on itunes yeah be nice full
video is available on youtube and as you
know those numbers are screw the roof
true the [ __ ] roof [ __ ] over there
and i gotta hire another grill man
orders were getting better in the market
for a [ __ ] line cook who knows one
let's go bring your own spatula we got
the aprons there you go um and then
patreon.com obviously i would be a
jerk off if i did not bring up
patreon.com you can sign up there you
get bonus episodes ayg weekly you get uh
bonus episodes of hard feelings which
are a whole nother podcast on its own
you get that
weekly who's that guy who's the guy that
started patreon who's behind that
[ __ ] johnny patreon
i went to school with his kid
steve and eric patrick uh i don't know i
don't know his name find him and kiss
his feet [ __ ] dude i'll give him a
[ __ ] handy yo one of the founders of
patreon's name is sam yam yo shout out
to the yam company yam incorporated all
of its subsidiaries and the whole yam
family
buddy i'm a yam man
you choose okay
you can join patreon for a five ten
twenty or fifty dollar level you choose
i don't care if it's kim jong-un i'll
tell you that right now the yam family i
hear all of their great people the shout
out to the yams shout out to uh yeah
sign up on patreon plus guys live shows
we're going to be coming to [ __ ]
texas oh yeah when this comes out in
like two or three weeks we're smoking
through texas do we got san antonio san
antone houston houston austin for the
moon tower austin for moon tower and
then closing it out over there in fort
worth dallas worth baby get some [ __ ]
tickets then we also have see dallas on
a sunday we have long island coming up
yes we do we got a
philadelphia philadelphia pennsylvania
better show and come the [ __ ] out the
27th of october helium comedy club let's
[ __ ] go the boys are coming home i'm
giving wedgies nuggies and swirlies the
line starts around the corner let's go
the theme song is worst behavior we're
coming back [ __ ] never loved us
uh yeah and we'll also have an nyc day
dropping very soon yes we will very
excited how about a nice shout out to
our producer extraordinaire do that the
magic man he makes us all look good he's
the brains behind that jersey shore
video that everybody's been falling all
over themselves about give it up for
t-bone mcmuffin god damn it it's toby
mcfarlane what's up dudes what up
t-boned nothing's over here i got a
frosty beverage just staying so ice-cold
thanks to this like a gentleman koozie
it's a plug-fest guy oh it's a plug
heavy plug fest like a gentleman koozie
i'm on a three-day pass to plug fence
i wear them as mittens
i put a testicle in each one of them the
real story is [ __ ] jeff bozo's over
here ordered four million of these
things
we got them clambering up the studio
jeff bozos is so good
this guy well you're not getting your
cut then all right we're all backed up
on kindles over here
what
what no no no what are we doing yeah
we got a goofy one already what are we
doing we're drowning in gooseberries
i'm looking at 17 000 of them right now
i ordered a hundred thousand i ordered
more koozies and we have listeners my
mom
asked me to bring a couple home i said
how many she goes 12. i'm like what the
[ __ ] paddy yeah he's having a couple of
boys over you know what i mean also yeah
before foley starts giving away to merch
to all of his [ __ ] dirtbag family
members hey i need nine t-shirts for the
boy my aunt needs a my hand needs a
[ __ ] apron the whole nine yards keep
it moving to her shirt makes a great
christening gif i'll tell you that
we'll grow into it yeah wrap the baby in
this
tell them we're coming to death tell
them we're coming to texas no bunk c
looks like our roadies hey father you
ever you haven't been to texas you got
any family down here in texas
ah good stuff we're having a good time
gang [ __ ] family episode we're not
screwing around this up we're getting
into your patreon questions we're gonna
rattle them off [ __ ] kippy hit it
okay my job's over i did want to what
what would you like to say well
i want the floor i want to ask uh how
garbage you think this is i mean i
recently i recently discovered some
some previous employment from this
producer you uh you talk up so much okay
yeah are you aware that mr mcmullen used
to be a canvasser
really yeah hitting people up on the
street who'd you used to work for
oh my god i work for like four different
places what's the big one the aspca or
whatever that nobody ever gets the money
i'm not gonna listen to you get out of
my way okay
dude they were heavy in philly around
like 2008 to 2013. that's why we met
they were on every corner isn't it he
was there canvassing now no it's not he
came to philadelphia to canvas you were
a traveling canvasser
yeah they said gypsy canvasser
what are you doing how do you do it
who'd you work for i can't remember who
the big one was but they'd hit you up
and you just they knew
i think children international was the
name of the organization it sounds like
yes yeah they never get a dime of that
money oh no no it's dialogue direct is
the company total scam yeah it's a third
party yeah they're a for-profit company
who takes most of the money and then
gives a percentage to the
uh organization they represent you
[ __ ] sleazeball i did that too for
them you did well i'm in bed with some
[ __ ] shysters over here i look clean
as a whistle
no you don't got dandruff all over the
back of your shirt but just saying this
is more of a hard feeling i like it
um i did i told you i did it for the for
the cop the fraternal order police oh
yeah that's right you were enough you
were in the boiler room this guy [ __ ]
pump and dump ryan but that that brings
up a [ __ ] perfect transition this is
uh first question guys as you know
that's why i'm in the hot seat baby you
think i don't earn my keep around here i
know what's going on you don't see the
question delicate genius the super glue
seat maybe yeah yeah for the listener
fully super glued his seat together
before we record it like two ounces of
super glue is gonna hold he's gonna
fight back 400 pounds and my basketball
shoulder may or may not be stuck to the
scene to be quite honest all right i'll
see you guys later
that's like when you tuck the tablecloth
into your thinking it's the napkin all
right guys i'll see the whole table goes
i just stay here till you guys leave
come back tuesday morning i'm still
sitting here a long beard
oh man the big man's got the giggies
kippy's got his number today folks
very good
i don't know if the people find it as
funny as we do but i am loving it having
a good time over here
guys so as you know when you join
patreon we'll answer uh one of the perks
of joining the patreon as well answer
your garbage question uh shout out to
the yam family and the estate
um this one comes from dallas which
where we'll be holy [ __ ] this is a
[ __ ] plug around with dude
first time question what's the shortest
amount of time you've ever held a job
for cause question when do i get tickets
for the dallas show
okay fantastic question
i would go to ww
after i left patreon.com i would
probably stop
that's all the questions became
trying to grip hey sweet koozier if i
wanted to send cash directly to foley
where can i send it to that's a great
question as well
oh
okay all right let's get serious
screwing around what's going around got
business to attend to
i mean this isn't hyenas comedy club in
fort worth texas
[Laughter]
i'm sorry is it september 26th at seven
o'clock in fort worth texas did you just
check that on your movement watch
i gotta get a good night's sleep on my
helix
[Laughter]
fall asleep listen to my recons
stamp stock now
this is from dallas first time question
what's the shortest amount of time you
ever held the job for context i worked
at a bagel shop for four hours and a
rite aid for 90 minutes
right age that's hard to do because
there's training yeah that's like a
corporate job you're going to pass a
background check there's something they
can't be letting you by the pills
90 minutes jesus christ i so want to
know
if it was him or there's no way right
aight fired him in 90 minutes that's got
to be like i'm not doing this
i've i think that's what sounds like a
walk out to me i've taken jobs where i'm
gonna where i'm like there's no way i'm
sticking around here i always wanted to
take one last waiting jet waiting tables
job so i could quit the first day
oh just to like
make myself feel better hey
where this is where you keep the napkins
[ __ ] you i'm out of here all right man
what the [ __ ]
take out your your 14 years of waiting
one guy i always wanted to have a job
that i didn't need but i was never in
that in that position where i was barely
barely in that position now
can i just keep sundays
i did a brunch nobody wants to work
during the day right
i had uh
i worked at a a
forklift battery place
when i was in college quit bragging
was that an internship it was it wasn't
interesting it was an unpaid internship
where like i wasn't getting credits
or paid i was just like
this was back in the day when you could
that was still flying i'm like yeah just
come here and work type thing i would
send out not cold calling not knocking
on i would send out cold faxes
i just had like a list of fax numbers i
would just stand there like beep boop
bop boop fax like a one sheet over of
like hey did you ever get any bites what
no what the [ __ ] you gotta be some kind
of loser fall for that
the facts got you holy [ __ ] man yeah no
i never sold [ __ ] i was it was a very
short it was like i was supposed to come
in like every friday or something it was
like one of those things just so i'd
have it on my resume of like
really hit your foot on the gas didn't
you
dude who's running that company you
could ignore a call you can't ignore a
fact you can't walk away from a paper
kid
either way that sounds annoying as [ __ ]
all right that'll get your attention
yeah and i uh
i remember my dad had the fax machine
set up down in his office for a little
while yeah and like
up until like maybe like three years ago
i think we were still one at my mom in
the basement it's not hooked up but
there's still one and every once in a
while you'd be sitting there watching a
ball game and [ __ ] all of a sudden
you hear r2d2 going off in the corner
and you're like wire's been hit yeah
what the [ __ ] is this yeah and like some
menu will slide out
directly they know their market
hey angelo's hit us with the new with
the new special today
all right i'll get to scampi
[Music]
see if they'll do a salad with the pasta
i'll make a deal
[Music]
yeah but i left that i pulled in i think
on my second or third day maybe
i pulled in
hung up like still drunk from the night
before was it college like dollar beers
on a thursday night at like you know the
local [ __ ] watering hole
i pull in
i just
still drop like and just being like
there's no way i can go in there and do
this i was chugging a red gatorade
thinking it was gonna [ __ ] like just
hoping a string string a couple of hours
together and my boss walked by i was
like oh hey and i was like in the car
and i just like
i was in my mom's gray bravada just
[ __ ] hit the [ __ ] bricks dude it
was and even worse it was in it was in a
stone parking lot because it wasn't like
a warehouse like you know so
as i did it like how they hit them with
dust and pebbles
like [ __ ] sprayed them it's like
[ __ ] later sticking around losers
starting my own facts company yeah
here well he hit me up a couple years
later he was getting together like a
soccer magazine or something he's like
you or anybody you know want to sell i'm
like nah man i'm [ __ ] out of here
this guy said yeah this guy's got the
worst [ __ ] products in the world he's
pitching [ __ ] to you yeah
no it was more like do you want to sell
out that do you want to work for us
he's like why don't you want to work for
me the first time
didn't i leave you in a parking lot
somewhere
pulled out like one of the duke boys
great question that was a fantastic
question
um i made it a week one place i think
it's the shortest
me and my brother i think we talked
about this me and my brother got these
jobs it was like a it was a union
contract but they needed non-union
people but they were paying union rates
yeah they will pay like that's with the
union i forget exactly what it is but
they're like you can take on non-union
guys but you have to pay them like
two-thirds of a regular union a family
friend owned the company yeah and they
hired we were we were
should have been outside your house with
a [ __ ] rat we were lining coax cable
through a high school and we had no idea
what we were doing just [ __ ]
breathing like asbestos and insulation
every every day in the like in the in
the drop ceiling so we're like crawling
through there
bull and his brother like coax goes in
copper comes out
somebody put a bunch of empty wire in
here
just all pvc
yeah they realized we had no idea what
we were doing yeah of course of course
um
all right let's see here
this is from uh mavi i think it is
uh yeah uh
you have to have a question read ever
needed to have a paper license plate
taped to your back window
i see them more and more these days and
i don't know why i had one for too long
on the teague when i got it so sometimes
if they don't have yeah it's like a
temporary
plate
right
but i don't get when i got the kia they
had i left there with the [ __ ] steel
on the car the front and the back the
new new york jaws really yeah damn yeah
right away but when i bought the it was
i think it's more used cars when i
bought
i bought it from like a rinky dink like
you know one of those like uh they have
the corner lot and there's like a
trailer on it type thing i never
understood that and there's all
different kinds of cars yet they stay in
business for like 50 years yeah there's
good [ __ ] you make good
good margins on them there's one there's
one in our area that's been that's been
there forever i've never seen anybody
buy a car there and they keep getting
bigger and bigger every year yeah i
don't know i we bought a car it was like
a family friend or something like that
friend of my stepdads
same thing and the day i turned in i
finally took it down you know a year
late or whatever like you had a
temporary tag for a year i think it was
on there i just never taken it off like
is it paper yeah
what it looked like old homework by the
end it was like a little frazzled for
sure the light had got the sun got into
it a little bit
jesus christ um and uh
they
when i turned my [ __ ] uh
montego in there was still the p the top
piece of tape was on the inside of the
back window still i would every time i
looked in my room oh you had it inside
yeah of course oh that's i'm talking
about the ones that are that are where
the license plate should be the nice the
paper white ones they gotta last like an
hour i mean when i see them i'm always
i'm always happy for people i'm like oh
this guy got a new car you know i see a
lot of people can't afford license
plates dude in the [ __ ] window that
is a tough tough look yeah i would not
ride with my parents in the car
if our license plate was in the [ __ ]
rear window well it's a temporary until
the tags come then the tags came i put
them on and just i guess i never took
down the piece of tape was there for i
think i had that card for like eight
years
boys
i just found maybe my favorite story in
are you garbage history i'm listening
used car king of new york busted in
prolific paper license plate scam oh
there you go
more and more of them this fool sold as
many as 3 000 phony paper tags in the
past year alone pocketing 250 thousand
dollars in cash that doesn't seem like
that much though
for three thousand
each one's about eight g's if i'm doing
the math right that's not right yeah it
is three thousand times eight thousand
is more than two hundred and fifty
thousand what is it
uh it would be 800
huh
800 to 800 000
what
no said he made 200 and some thousand
yep he sold 3 000 of them yeah for like
83 bucks a piece yeah oh 83 bucks yeah
not eight thousand bucks a piece okay
but here but
he's like a billionaire yeah what the
[ __ ] what are you ready for the that
doesn't if you're doing a scheme that
doesn't seem i'm scheming bigger than
that shout out to the yams are are you
ready for the for the ayg kicker okay
ocasio whose criminal record dates to
1996 was arrested tuesday at a long
island buffalo wild wings nice
going out in style that's like 250k
untaxed in your bank account covered in
blue cheese you got your [ __ ] wing
sauce on your face what took you so long
as they walk up
smoking a celery stick
[Laughter]
the waitresses are all crying in the
corner they took jimmy
uh
yeah that's uh that's a tough look that
the temporary tag or plate is bad news
man bad [ __ ] news all right in the
same vein this is from mclin i have not
had one red yet ever give the finger to
a student driver
you got to be a real cold bastard to do
that give the kid a break
anybody that does that man i don't know
how anybody has the patience for that
the patience i don't have the [ __ ]
teacher
my ink i don't even like it when you're
driving
oh my god i'd be a wreck oh dude sit
next to some [ __ ] 16 year old i did
see one time we were about 14 13 i know
probably younger they're never nice cars
either they're always tough looks yeah
yeah yeah
um
the big thing for us imagine driving
that off off shift you guys that's your
only if that's the main mode of
transportation
pulling up to the north side on the top
pulling up to the bar at that time to
get laid in the student driver car
you ever see two brakes yeah you're all
[ __ ] up in the passenger seat hitting
the brake on your buddy
[Laughter]
hey it's a green light jerk off
now we're talking
how do we get our hands on one of these
things
i did see one time uh
we were we were
playing laser tag
at like the at the ultra zone shout out
to the did you have ultra zones by you
there was a couple of them i think they
were like a bigger change there's a
couple now i don't know it's called
urban urban air there's a couple now in
there those are trampolines yeah okay
yeah yeah we didn't we didn't have a
laser tag uh set up yeah ultrazone they
were by like there was always like one
by a mall i felt like there was a
handful of them so i assumed they were
more widespread i only knew two kids
that had laser tag one was my cousin and
we only had one parties no just in
general what do you mean i wasn't in
that life i wasn't about that it came
out you were too old when it got cooking
i don't know i remember you were cause i
was like on the cusp of like this is
corny but it's still kind of fun when it
when it got popular i just remember my
cousin had one but just one do you mean
one i don't know just one house yeah one
talking about going and playing no just
one gun
i'm sorry i have to pause i'm gonna [ __ ]
myself again i'm so sorry jesus
gang this podcast is brought to you by
our good friends at better help yep is
there something holding you back
something you want to get off your chest
you got to go to better health and get
yourself straightened out they match you
with a licensed therapist in the privacy
of your home within 48 hours kippy
straighten them out yeah guys it's not a
crisis hotline it's not a self-help line
it's professional counseling done
securely online professional guys the
pandemic i mean we're still in it we're
still kicking around you know you don't
want to have to go sit in a lot sitting
here you can't be sitting in some
waiting room reading some uh sports
illustrated from 98 come on yeah and
plus you can hit like uh the the place i
used to go i could hear the person
before me then i know the person while
i'm in there the person who's waiting
behind me can hear me crying about my
dad or whatever you don't need it right
uh it's easy
you can do it worldwide you just log
into your account anytime you can send a
personal message to your counselor you
get a timely and thoughtful response
flushing schedule weekly videos or phone
sessions like we said no waiting rooms
it's easy peasy uh lemon squeezy better
help is committed to facilitating great
therapeutic matches so they make it easy
and free to change counselors if you
want to look at that i mean what are we
doing here what are we doing it's easy
uh
so visit betterhelp.com
garbage that's betterhelp h-e-l-p and
join over the 1 million people who have
taken charge of their mental health with
the help of an experienced professional
look at that everyone's getting
everyone's taking care of their mental
health you got to do it too get on it
special offer for ru garbage issues
listeners you'll get 10 off your first
month at betterhelp.com garbage one more
time guys get a pen get a paper write it
down
betterhelp h-e-l-p-dot-com
garbage kipi raycon wireless earbuds
best in a biz i'll say it again a raycon
wireless earbuds i'll say it one more
raycon wireless earbuds but you don't
got them you got the other brand i'm the
one bee bopping down the street to my
upbeat tunes with my raycons in your
coolness factor went up 15 when i
i'll be on the phone you think i'm
talking to you i put you on hold boom
i'm right back to the playlist
you walk around with ceo vibes
i love them they fit perfectly in your
ear they're very comfortable battery
lasts forever volume's unbelievable the
best love them and when you put them in
it goes power on and i think you feel
like a robot oh yeah yeah check it by
tuning in
uh guys bring me sandwiches
they started half the price of other
premium audio
but they sound just as good i think
better and they feel better in your ears
i'll be honest with you they fit
comfortably in there also i'm gonna hit
you with they come with a 45-day
happiness guarantee so if you so you
really can't lose give them a try and
you'll see what the big man is telling
you about oh yeah um right now uh are
you garbage listeners can get 15 off the
raycon order to at buy raycon dot com
slash garbage one more time guys that's
by raycon dot com slash garbage you'll
save 15 on ray cons you'll be cool like
foley yeah you will be a little bit of a
robot you'll look cool to your friends
you'll sound cool on the phone you'll be
bopping skating around that's by
raycon.com garbage do it yeah now back
to the show
yeah no no no ultrazone no ultrazone no
yeah i i meant yeah the place we never
had it nobody ever had one at the house
that's how see i think you're thinking
lasered i think you missed
uh
uh the beginning of laser tag that was
sold as a home gun yeah but they were
never good no suck that's what i'm
saying i'm saying you go to ultrasonic i
didn't start getting corporate until you
guys were kids well kip i can tell you
there's some unhappy customers of the
ultrazone down there in benson salem pa
benson sail on this guy [ __ ] learn
how to read before you before you come
at me and the good people lower bucks
county okay where do you live benson
hedge
[Laughter]
benson hedges pa can you buy me a ben
salem cigarette please it's ben salem ya
bozo all right well this review is of
the ultrazone and bensonhurst
is from ryan
who's a grown-ass man with sunglasses
and backwards hat and his avatar for
google reviews which you stink already
uh one star review from one year ago so
ultrazone's still going man they're
still can't let he's been holding a
grudge for a couple of years i think i'm
gonna i'm gonna wait and get him i
thought it closed a [ __ ] decade ago
this is unreal i will begin this review
by stating that i am utterly disgusted
and disappointed all caps with the
unsportsmanlike environment
[Laughter]
there was guys covering their packs i
shot him he had his hand over his
dad i got you i got you
it's a grown man with a car payment the
staff allowed doubt it by the way yeah
the staff allowed one of their friends
slash co-workers named steve could
parentheses confirmed by two employees
god
to participate using a vest that was
very clearly programmed to not disable
its gun when shot the player put the
season steve my god did not leave the
arena with everyone else and stayed
inside the arena
[Laughter]
the arena of combat i mean
i will have my vengeance in this life or
another game
that's what you have to do two men enter
steve's leaves what he wants
uh not only does this kind of behavior
show a clear and blatant disregard for
fair play but also a high level of
unprofessionalism as a business if
management takes the time to read these
reviews i hope you take the time to
speak with your employees parentheses
and steve
about this stuff steve needs to hear
about what's going on here be corrected
in the future ultrasones got to work on
their vetting process huh
i mean it's also like
you ever shoot a gun before yeah yeah
yeah
it was uh
yeah the ultra's that specific ultra
zone was the one we would dabble in for
sure however benson and hyde they threw
a nice [ __ ] slice at you buddy they
had a birthday party room that would
knock your [ __ ] socks off i'm telling
you like the bellagio in there
to play the games
you know it's not too shabby i don't
[ __ ] shake a stick at it a picture of
soda i mean we've talked about this
before but if you come heavy with a
[ __ ]
i don't see i like pepsi out of a
picture
of soda you breathe a little bit
packed with ice
pouring it from the side so you get a
little ice in your cup that was hold on
when you were a kid and you saw a dad do
that for the first time oh that was an
older person thing my head explode my
cousins could do it i couldn't oh yeah
we would go to skill we would go to
sam's and you said you'd get a pie and
you'd sit at sam's pizza down here in
wildwood and they would give you a
picture oh they would yeah they would
give you a pitcher of birch beer we
didn't get to do dine in service um we
did it on the boardwalk like animals oh
when we went yeah yeah yeah by the way i
i've said this i want to say it publicly
i know it's been covered uh by the
experts but one of the best slices of
pizza i've ever had in my life sam's
pizza is a home remedy holds up home
that's not just good short pizza it's
[ __ ] good pizza fantastic
i think gutter i'm toby mcmullen and i
didn't got a ride
the tomatoes really shut up yeah kick
rocks it's like the best pizza from a
chalky cheese you'll ever have
you're nuts
how
i [ __ ] exist get a haircut and call
your father yeah right
jesus christ
prez gave it a seven nine yeah come on
and you were like he you gotta respect
what he says you gotta respect it's the
only review of his that i've ever
disagreed with oh my god you're who's
pressured into it but you're trying to
follow him around like dave matthews
you're a [ __ ] bozo don't you kill
that fly there
don't he's been landing on me tickles my
leaves on your face all right this is
it's episodes broncos taking him home
with me um
all right let's see uh
this is uh this is from elizabeth and
we've touched on this i'm sure on the
side i think you have i haven't have you
ever gone sledding on something that
wasn't an actual sled i still think
about it to this day i've discussed it
multiple times in the podcast the famous
unices hill in union meeting
pennsylvania
the cardboard
snow sled yeah me and my brother
day office school
new in town just moved in the town line
apartments i've admits honestly
[Laughter]
didn't have a lot of friends still don't
i've admits sewn to his jacket
[Laughter]
so he doesn't lose it
plus i got a pot roast in the oven
um
yeah my mom's off from work
i feel like she did it to be strong
there's no way that this woman thought
that aerodynamically that this was gonna
work she don't know what's going on pure
physics she said she used to do it when
she was a kid listen the 20s were a
weird time he was like using it
using a cardboard box as a [ __ ] sled
we just went
into this yeah you're not going anywhere
ah do you remember what kind of box it
was
a cereal
a fruit loop sock
ah it's stunk man the other kids are
looking at us like we were aliens it was
[ __ ] brutal oh of course talk about
not making friends
not to mention she tried it and rolled
down the hill now she's covered in snow
yelling at us
i told you [ __ ] just wouldn't work
she's selling us out
oh man it was a tough look
yeah and i remember we went
to like a kmart or a walmart
because we had just moved so we had to
get rid of our for some reason the sleds
couldn't make the trip so they got 86
and a yard sale the week before we
[ __ ] blew out of town
um
but we price checked a couple sleds in
kicking the tires probably like five ten
bucks you know a little circle jaunch
the saucers no
no we're not getting that
now let's go embarrass ourselves in the
new neighborhood kids
i love you patty
good stuff
yeah that's a tough look you you
probably had all the hot [ __ ] cause you
were a divorce kid playing [ __ ] both
ends against the middle you were out
like car shopping probably go to the lot
and see what they have
probably with the [ __ ] handbrake a
little brick you have the handbrake
[ __ ] scumbag the two-seater
picking up chicks
[Laughter]
um you're turfing me yeah we had we were
in a big sled
maybe like just one or two of the cheapo
uh
plastic drawns you know what i mean we
had a couple of the radio flyers left
over those wings we had one left death
trap i don't know where that that was
what i was gonna say i don't know where
the [ __ ] it came from the wooden ones
with the rails on it the with the red
metal rails
and we would die in those things we
would wax up the ramp my dad's like you
gotta wax these up i'm like all right
dude that's i went down my [ __ ] hill
like to cooking down this thing
you could have went in august this thing
these things were so slick yeah but you
had those were for old time winters they
were for winters when it was like 40
below yeah they weren't for fluffy snow
no you need to be on like a ski hill you
had to go down you got to go down a tire
track on that thing yeah dude yeah those
things would get cooking good luck
steering with that thing oh no you're
[ __ ] [ __ ] dead god's driving there
god take the wheel on the radio flyer
they only slended in a compartment for
your smokes
had a cigarette lighter in it
[ __ ] that yeah those things are [ __ ]
tough the best my dad brought he goes
yeah we got this and
i had been in every inch of our house
and he broke that out you i don't know
what i still to this day think he had it
in the crawl space that was the on i'm
like we don't own that where did you get
this he goes yeah this was mine when i
don't know it was his or her something
jesus man this thing was rickety
i tell you that
for sure dude
like being on a fire escape downtown
it was like that scene in cool runnings
where they show the inside of the sled
and the bolts are falling out and [ __ ]
like they're just going too fast and the
old sled break you're going backwards
down there meet my brother in the bath
practice in leans
you want to live don't you
hey kipp are you dead yet
great question oh man i want to make
sure we go i want to go sledding this
year
okay
i mean you're too big to be that's too
much velocity you have to lose a little
couple a couple of pounds
take out a city bus i know jesus christ
that was like when we had bobby on for
the first time bobby talked about how he
hurt himself it's stupid that we made
the joke that he may have too much
momentum that he went through past the
end of the hill ends up on the highway
he keeps going gets caught in an easy
pass
ah that's pretty good stuff
um all right this one's from kevin um
does anyone
does anyone you know
fish without a standard fishing pole
they're using something else
that canoodling that [ __ ] you get
them on your it canoodling i don't know
any canoodlers it's it's just noodling
it's amazing how many attractive women
noodle i'll tell you that according to
instagram on tv yeah they're not you're
not gonna really find them at the bottom
you couldn't pay me a billion dollars to
get in that water let alone stick my
hand on the [ __ ] side of a creek into
rocks trying to [ __ ] go into a
[ __ ] catfish's summer home are you
out of your [ __ ] mind i'm there with
my pants
[Laughter]
hey where's he at
hey he said this hole right
what a problem little power bait on my
peepee you got a snorkel
oh man
no okay every once in a while going down
going down the shore going down the
beach you know a bunch of families would
come there was always somebody on the
fringes that usually didn't come down
or maybe they sent me that did their own
thing where the dad would like yeah do
something with like um
a spool of fishing line on like a wooden
stick he would like fish like that like
off the bridges we've i've i've like
attempted that more as of like it's a
summer day
and we have nothing as like a
nine-year-old and you're like oh well
today's gonna be 47 hours like i gotta
kill some time you know what i mean you
get into some mischief we would like
[ __ ] around with that but never like
yeah never knowing that is an adult
we're going to try to catch them it was
more like let's see if we can figure
this no this was their move he'd show up
with one of those primer buckets those
huge paint buckets and he'd have all
this [ __ ] in there like a couple of
[ __ ] things that cut the line and
bait and this and that goober like
didn't you rip your [ __ ] fingers off
with this yeah i don't [ __ ] with that
over to dicks get up get up we had a rod
and reel
um
let's see all right this one's from
joshua ever participate in your school's
talent show
no i could have done it i could have
done the senior class show
but i was in i was interested you guys
don't get me i was in an argument with
my girlfriend it didn't go
on stage or something
i can't remember what it was but i was
still working at west coast video and i
purposely didn't go and i picked up a
shift at west coast listen i'm gonna
pick up a shift i'd rather earn money
than spend money all right
you could have played sunny day i was in
uh i was in it in eighth grade
the senior class show not the senior
class show like the talent show like the
junior high i guess they won our junior
high was seventh eighth and ninth
i guess i was seventh or eighth grade
this band had got a friend like a group
there was like 10 people that played
instruments or sang or whatever out of
like all of you know the whole school or
whatever okay uh
and i had play they got in as a
guitarist a drummer and like these two
girls sang
and they needed a basis of course they
did uh talking about a super group
[Laughter]
this is how the eagles started by the
way
um and they were like hey did you play
the bass yeah yeah i had played the bass
i just wasn't like that tight with them
but they're like hey we're already in
and it was one of their original songs
like the girls originals it was like
he's he's these two broads i thought
they were like you know christina
aguilera and [ __ ] britney spears
meanwhile i was just trying to slap the
[ __ ] bass you know what i mean
stage diver kraut surf or something
um so yeah we played they were already
in so we just i just had it was like
just had to do a couple rehearsals with
them and then you know the then the big
show
and i remember
um oh my god the band so another this
group of kids that we knew
hey johnny you know the new sound you've
been looking for
[Music]
hey man the talent show's over unless
you know a fat kid with a cheap bowl cut
that can play the bass guitar
it was an ibanez
[Laughter]
[Music]
uh i was okay i carried anthony junior
up in your room wailing on that thing
i'm all my wing
how's the other thing it was getting
welded on in the back it's getting
pretty good
um
no i uh
get your noodle hooked up to an
amplifier
um
i uh
what the [ __ ] was gonna say oh but i
remember the [ __ ] the [ __ ] [ __ ]
music teacher i don't even know her name
she [ __ ] she thought we were like the
you know the symphony so the the
we were in seventh or eighth grade and
then the ninth graders were like the kid
the kid is still a phenomenal guitar
like [ __ ] melt your face heavy metal
like metallica [ __ ] and they played fade
to black
and at that point like it sounded you
got to follow that no they were closing
i mean come on what do they know how to
put a show
together [ __ ] i mean dude we were
playing falling down we opened up the
first half okay
um
but they played fade to black in my head
as a metallica fan i was like this is
like note it was it was probably not as
good but at the time i was like this was
phenomenal i just think because that was
such a complicated song for them to even
be able to do it
what i don't know who you are right now
what do you mean because that's a
complicated sign well no i'm saying as a
[ __ ] eighth grader
to watch there's these kids like
actually do a [ __ ] metallica song
well i was i was shocked i know i didn't
have the i didn't have the confidence to
do that
but we all wanted to watch it we were
like and they're like she was like no
you can't we're like let us go watch
them close out the [ __ ] show she's
like you are performers you have to stay
back i'm like i'm a [ __ ] i'm a
[ __ ] 300 pounder [ __ ] 12 year old
let me the [ __ ] out there what a [ __ ]
match
[ __ ] breaking my stones lady you're
working at [ __ ] a junior high right
now so i can't be retired after that one
show played a couple more
couple more dates couple more dates a
couple more t-shows for us it was uh uh
patience by guns and roses i've heard of
it there were a couple of bozos i think
in my brother's grade they could nail
the in your eyes at that time you nailed
it they were in there they were like
these they were the guys with the
acoustic guitars at parties they got
together this one kid sung it and yeah
it brought the [ __ ] house down my
cousin also brought the house down at
our talent show doing a michael jackson
impersonation that she had done for
years
[ __ ] crowd pleaser real original
murder impersonator get out of here
we were writing originals man i was
playing falling down you should have
heard me waylon i was like
that's pretty much what it was like
it was like open e then like
you know
one of the guitarists or whatever had a
wireless he like brought dude he was
walking around the [ __ ] gym cafeteria
slash auditorium
he was killing it by then
killing it by the vending machines
i stole that i think from bill ingle
um
yeah he uh he was walking around i
remember just being like this is
the height of showmanship right here
he's kicking banana pudding in parents
faces
it was a scene
it was a good time um all right moving
right along this is for mark have you
ever been skitching what the [ __ ] yeah
you know what sketching is oh my god i
got broke off hammer drunk sketching on
a cab got speed get you hold on
schedules when you hold your like on
rollerblades a bike or a skateboard you
hold on the back of a car like back to
the future yes okay there was a sega
game sega i think it was called skitchin
where that was the game we had to like
dodge things and switch call and
whatever trash it was a great time that
is a garbage [ __ ] video game
i tried to buy it i'm not even lying i
try to buy it at a [ __ ] yard sale in
my neighborhood and my mom was like
absolutely not it was five dollars i'm
like this is a steal these these old
these this old bastard doesn't know the
price of [ __ ] skitching it should
have been like mine i got skitching it
should have been 39.99
sounds like a rash you get yeah
it's all sketched up ah but yeah sorry
continue t-bone oh i just the cab took
off there were two girls in the back
seat one of them blocked eyes at me i
gave her the like the sh be cool and she
was like okay
and then she opened her door it was like
3 a.m ashland avenue in chicago this cab
took off just gunned it i
instantaneously got speed wobbles got
pitched sideways i'm mid-air and i just
see this chick looking back at me just
like oh [ __ ] all me
i'm kind of glad that happened slam
sketching rolled both ankles hit my head
got a concussion didn't walk for like
three days if i was in an uber and i saw
somebody i'm definitely opening the door
the [ __ ] out of here yeah i had uh my
buddies uh who will remain nameless but
they were i don't know if they were
gonna try to beat the cab or whatever
but one of them was like got out like
tried to get out before the cab had like
fully come to a stop and he knew
something was up and this is what back
in the dish is way pre uber this is
philly like two thousand [ __ ] eight
or whatever
where those cabs were they're relatively
lawless you could like still smoke in
them it was like you know
and as mr derosa says international
water it is it's international waters
and
i guess he thought they were gonna run
because my one buddy opened the door and
i think he got out of the light was like
i'm out like but there was still like
four other people in the car or whatever
and he was it was like this old-timer
who was like i've been beat too many
this ain't happening again
[ __ ] lays on it hops on 676. hops on
the highway jesus yeah the kid hanging
out no he's gone he pulls out a gun and
he's like no one's going anywhere
they're like what the [ __ ] that dude
we'll pay you a bit we're just kitchen
man
he pulled over on the side what he
pulled over on the side of the highway
and they got off on the on 670 that'll
like jump over the barriers and [ __ ] hey
thanks sir thank you
yeah keep the change that's not
skitching though that's just falling out
of a cat that's being a drunk [ __ ] in
[ __ ] 2008 toby skitched yeah
you just learned what it was 30 seconds
ago
well you look like a sketcher i'll be
honest with you i can really see it
though it looks like you're sketching a
little bit down there to be honest with
you
a little jammed up in your [ __ ]
underwear region
your balls are sketching
the balls are sketching on your wiener
um all right let's see here uh
i don't have cats uh but do you this is
for you two i guess do you keep a spray
bottle for your misbehaving cat
i would never spray my little stinky no
or a can of pennies for your dog i guess
if you shake it it scares them
i keep that keep that for my younger
brother
there's some nickels at him
yeah my mom had that when we were kids
um i think it was for us though that was
a retirement fun she'd squirt us with
the watermelon
we uh
my buddy's dog
had an electric collar
oh we used to try those on all the time
oh yeah in front of the tv but there was
a clicker like this like the second
level there was a clicker that you could
click it to train them
and it would like give them like a low
voltage shock i guess so then the dog
just became afraid of the remote
so we would sneak in late at night and
that the thing would start barking and
you just [ __ ] grabbed the closest
remote and pointed at him he would
[ __ ] shy
keep your [ __ ] mouth shut dirt bags
hey i play the game it's either that i
get [ __ ] i get grounded dude i just
remembered that my mom we would play out
in the neighborhood she had a dog
whistle she would blow to get us to come
back to the house dog whistle you can't
hear those
i think you can they're just very high
no not not not like a dog was like only
dogs like
a whistle yeah
yeah but i think they're like more like
a lot was it one of those old school
long ones yeah jesus christ did she do
like a little
remember those little whistles with
little fans in them
those things were hot for a minute i
don't know what you mean
the kazoo yeah no not a kazoo what am i
a [ __ ] jerk off yes the little
they're like tube ones and they have
little fans inside and you go
no i don't really
just call yourself a musician
hey you want to be in my talon show
wonder why the band broke up yeah oh
that's good my my one neighbor had uh
they had a cowbell to call him home for
dinner when i was real little
there's a lot of jokes there i'm leaving
on the table he's here
he was a little chubby kid too he'd hear
it banging throughout the neighborhood
for him to come home for dinner he come
home wearing his shirt what's going on
mom
a little fat kid busting through the
bushes
[Laughter]
all right let's see uh this one's from
steve uh
have you or anyone in your family ever
used a stapler to fix the drooping
fabric interior roof liner
of your car jesus christ that was wordy
yeah it was wordier i cleaned it up no
we tucked it on the sides like a
gentleman
i'm not going to puncture it going to
puncture a good roof yeah those things
were a tough look yeah but that would
start hanging down
what was that that that doesn't happen
in cars now no cheap fabric yeah bad
glue i don't know was the demise of the
auto industry i don't know what to tell
you kid yeah detroit wasn't the same
[ __ ] dropping it
we got bad ceilings and slow sleds yeah
shit's changing yeah [ __ ] jar full of
pennies if it was a secondhand car if it
was like one of us driving we just cut
that [ __ ]
yeah that's just getting ripped out yeah
100
um all right let's see this one is from
uh
sorry this was a this is from sam have
you ever drove a dirt bike in a
residential area i don't think you've
ever been on a dirt bike i've been on a
mini bike once and a kid this dirtbag
kid in our neighborhood had a track
around around the back of his house and
i wrote yeah oh oh man that is the wrong
side of the door oh
this place was i don't even know if he
had parents i'll be honest with you sure
you know what i mean it's tough um yeah
i wrote it once was petrified almost
burned my leg on the on the i was scared
of burning my leg on the muffler
and that was that was it for me yeah
yeah now never
i don't know if i've ever ridden a
proper dirt bike we had a mini bike
growing up my brother had a go-kart
uh
and then we rode quads and stuff like
friends had quads that we would ride now
yeah but never we were i was petrified
of those things before i even knew what
it was somebody got hurt on on the quad
there was always that was that's how you
break you're not breaking your neck
apparently in the 80s and 90s everybody
was breaking their necks i think a lot
of people did i think there was a little
wall they were completely unsafe back
then yeah yeah yeah
i did i dumped my uh
mini bike first day i got it i think i
told you my dad got him for christmas
and my mom was like don't get him a [ __ ]
i'm sure it was a contentious
conversation but he was like
dude you don't think i'm gonna buy this
kid [ __ ] happiness [ __ ] mini bike
drove it the first day guy [ __ ]
dumped it
tore up my [ __ ] arm
i was like what happened to your arm the
next day i'm like i fell at school
it's christmas break i've been in school
nine days i'm like
been practicing on the base
[Laughter]
you'll see
[Laughter]
you'll be sorry ma um
this is from devry are you garbage if
all four tires
are different brands
yes yes 100 yeah yeah i'm not gonna say
i haven't been jammed up in situations
like that but
it's trashy but i get what you gotta do
what you gotta do you know if you need a
new tire you only got 150 bucks you
can't have a [ __ ] what are you gonna
do you know we're gonna replace them all
just so that [ __ ] up the alignment on
the car i just want you kids out there
to know that not the brands the sizes
no the sizes no different treads
i'm telling you i've just been going
through it i've been through like four
tires
in the last year i think it's more here
you're not really balanced when you're
cruising you got a heavy payload car
drive sideways
uh
[Music]
this one's from brandon uh
first question have you ever known
anyone who married multiple spouses with
the same name so you like married two
trishs
that would be too weird for me too weird
also too if like my uncle brought home
or like you know my cousin brought home
like hey this is megan and then like
four years later this is megan but
that's
you know there's something here yeah
you're a serial killer there's something
kooky going on yeah no yeah get tinder
something
i didn't even like the second marriage
no matter who they were
really oh yeah if somebody got divorced
then you're at like their second wedding
no i don't think so i don't think i
don't have any i think my opinions on
that are well documented
yeah i don't think i have any uh
other than my
my parents
nobody else had like a second marriage
that i had to it like none of my friends
have been married like i'm not at the
age now where like you're at the age
where somebody could get married
divorced and then remarried
i'm still a little too young for that
yeah unless i got married at like 22. i
don't have that i know one of my boys
just got married
at 45. late bloomer when are you going
to get married moving on
waiting out your marriage first trying
to get my hands on you all right go for
the money
dual income we could do it
get a better tax break nice insurance
rates i like it
um
all right let's see this is relatively
on the same uh same path as that this is
chuck uh new to patreon first comment
does your family keep we've talked about
this does your family keep a record of
cash that each guest provides as a gift
for a party confirmation weddings etc
then gift that family accordingly based
on their initial gift
when they have a party of their own what
the [ __ ] was that what no yeah well
people say that say one more time slower
oh you keep track of how much you
somebody gives you so then when they
have an event you give them the same
amount
no what i i would no that's insane to me
but people do know what you give at a
wedding oh of course like i'm not even
that guy like i'm not the guy to be like
well they only gave me a hundred or they
gave me five hundred oh yeah you know as
you're going through the car just like
buy one though all right steve i didn't
know you were [ __ ] doing that well
yeah um so you do know and it does sit
with you you do remember
a hundred percent i think i got an
amazon gift card from you that i'd
pretty sure you took from your mom that
what was that for my wedding
oh well i wasn't invited lucky you got
anything
[ __ ] prick
look i didn't give you a bill for
an order of crab cakes and some watered
down martinis
bought my own chocolate fountain
yeah no that's that that's kooky i'll
tell you this though but i think the
power move would be to keep track of it
and then when you go you give up
well sure that's why i wouldn't flex and
give the same thing i would go i want
you to know i'm better you gave me 200
here's three don't think i don't know
because i do
i notice the uh if i if i give a nice
gift
i i will say i am looking for the thank
you card at some point yeah you know
waiting on a couple right now to be
honest with you
should be coming my way soon because i
usually don't get them i usually get a
tongue-in-cheek hey thanks for coming
yeah well they're not really happy
you're there to be honest with yeah i
mean now they have to deal with a bounce
check
i went to this broad's house i didn't
steal none of the percocets and i don't
get a thank you i don't get to thank you
[Laughter]
i do you the courtesy and not robbing
you blind
i could have took that silverware but i
didn't where we just did robbie and
casey's wedding and you wrote you
spelled her name wrong on the envelope
i fixed it
no you didn't relax well what is this
[ __ ]
what is it
ladies and gentlemen he tried he
squirmed he left
first of all i just wrote r
and k but just
not thinking and then i changed it to a
c i made it look cool
as in c i'm an idiot
you can't turn a k into a c yeah you
can't yeah you can turn the e into a b
maybe no i got cause i drew it out like
calligraphy like i did the i made it
look like print looked cool
it did
it didn't and i called you out
immediately when we gave the cards to
robbie
fair enough that's what i gotta do what
are you gonna do yeah he also was like
what are you animals you because that we
gave doing the next morning because like
yeah we gave it to him the next morning
you don't want to get lost on the table
or something sure i need especially with
that i needed i needed eye contact when
i handed that over he made fun of me
because i didn't have i was like i was
like i was like a [ __ ] bread truck
that was a transfer
of funds
i needed a receipt for that yeah
no no well he called us out because we
walked up to robbie like we were leaving
the brunch the next day hey thanks a lot
and i go here mine's just blank like i
didn't write to robbing because also
it's like you know who you are it's not
like it's going to mix it up they get
confused with that stuff what do you
mean was there a card inside that had
your name on it yeah of course oh i had
my mine was watermarked
so he knows
the bills
have a special ink on them
if he wrote an h fully on every bill
it was like a hot script in hollywood
sealed it in wax
with your initials i would love to start
doing that yeah someone does i feel like
i just watched something where like
that's it ain't that big of a deal it's
like you could do it with like with
crayons i think you can melt the crayon
and then just you got to get your family
crest stamper
that's all you gotta get is your family
cred stamper guys you know what i'm
talking about the wax on the cards on
envelopes it's real classy h fully crest
is a chicken wing in a broken snow
blower
and an unplugged an unplugged dryer
absolutely those things are cool um all
right this one's from zach i haven't had
a question read yet has anyone in your
family ever been cast as a member at
medieval times
cass is a member they call people they
actually call people out from the crowd
no i
i mean if they ever worked at medieval
times i don't know
i don't know what he's asking never been
never been either no
would love to go oh we could go that
could be a thing we do i wouldn't might
get my hand on one of them turkey legs
oh i did go i went in uh i went in uh
junior higher elementary school they
took us it smelled like horse [ __ ] i
would imagine it would i don't remember
it's gonna be tough to eat around that i
think they're johnny on the spot with
the cleanup yeah i feel like they got
him horseshit
come on well i don't think they're not
keeping the horses in there the horses
are like kept outside and then troll you
know they
they're still taking dumps in there come
on i think less though they ask them hey
do this outside before the showtime
you're performers you can't be [ __ ]
out there i don't know i could i can't
be [ __ ] during a performance i don't
think i could i don't think i could eat
even with the remote smell of horse or
horseshit i don't recall to be honest
with you uh i also just remembered it
being lost just like this
it's tough for me to get lost in that
how are they serving food in there too
with that going i mean it's a [ __ ] ch
it's a turkey leg it's not food it's not
it's not like a fork which is not a chef
tasting i think there would be some type
of fda regulations
fda i don't know yeah i know you don't
know because that doesn't make any sense
is that what gave me away
[Laughter]
um
yeah no never but there's one right in
jersey we could totally go i know
he knows guys
cena cenos all right this one's from
mark um do you have uh wait do you or
have you ever shopped at a grocery store
that had the anti-theft wheels on the
carts
that really
tells you something about where you live
in a multitude of ways
because if you're living in a place
where people are stealing the carts it's
a bad luck it's a bad luck
and it's also if they're stealing the
card so much that they have to do that
like i like i take my mom's neighborhood
like they don't have them and also like
no one's stealing a car and if they do
it's like yeah just take the one like
you know what i mean they don't care
that some one gets taken a year or a
month or whatever yeah you got to be
losing a lot of carts to invest in that
kind of technology yes i don't know how
they do that there's an invisible fence
or if it's a radio shock collar it's got
to be something or there's just some guy
in a computer room like hit 32 and then
he [ __ ] sees it's like bait car
[Laughter]
seizes the engine on oh man
that's a tough look shopping carts
outside
of a supermarket and supermarket parking
lot are the toughest look
sure you see a guy walking down the
street probably no one's ever pushing
that down a street they probably should
be walking down no it's always they're
on the shoulder they're like there's a
bumper in a lot of highways under
bridges under overpasses that's where
you see the solo shopping cart yeah it's
a tough yeah tough tough look
frightening
i was feeling i was just somewhere where
someone had one
and i was like we drove we were wherever
we were driving there was a shopping
cart on the one side of the road i can't
remember where we were no but like i was
like
like a friend oh i think it was my
mother-in-law took one what yeah
i think she returned it oh no what they
had is they had the basket that's what
they had they stole a basket
yeah this handheld i know exactly what
you're talking about i don't know now
listen now those i wouldn't mind
stealing it i gotta give you it was a
pretty we went to we had like a picnic
it was like [ __ ] perfect i don't know
she bought it or what
but it was in the apartment and we took
it i was like this thing's [ __ ] this
is a good move yeah sanitize that up
real quick i got a freshie yeah
i like that move it wasn't too bad but i
remember looking at i saw that in the
house i'm like these don't belong in
homes i know that but it's a pretty good
snag i got to give it to you
she's good she's got a sleeve of those
produce bags
that's what you take your luncheon
oh man they got a bucket full of twist
ties too i remember my dad i don't know
i think it was just looking back
the way my dad would operate a twist
high it was like he invented oh it's
crazy and i remember as a kid i could i
don't know if i didn't have enough
torque
the dexterity to hold it tight and get
it i couldn't put a twist tie on to save
my life meanwhile this guy's making
balloon animals that and how they
stirred [ __ ] like how good they how fast
they can make a spoon moving something i
was like what are you [ __ ] superman
well we used to talk i think we've
mentioned this off air but uh the thing
for us was ice cream
with like a little bit of hershey's
syrup like briar's shirt a little bit
hershey and then my dad would [ __ ]
whip it and he was the only one and the
kids were two i don't know if i again
didn't have them it didn't yeah but like
he would like to wet and then i did it
as an adult i was like oh this is funny
talk about blow your hair back simple
breyer's vanilla and a little bit of
[ __ ] hershey's whipped that up in the
soft serb
get the kids brush your teeth put some
listerine in because it's [ __ ] good
night yeah
that is the best that is a wrap
tough to recreate on the second bowl too
oh because there's already i don't know
what it was but how going back and
recreating that was tough
yeah yeah i don't know if i ever had to
uh do it on multiple bulls all right
moving on uh we gotta uh let's do like
two more than we got yeah get out of
here let's see we did the uh dropping of
the roof fair
uh so from mark have you ever been named
in a restraining order
god no yeah no jesus christ i don't even
think anybody i know that has
admitted to me they've been named i'm
sure i know somebody who has been in a
restraining order sure
a boyfriend girlfriend type thing
husband's wife type thing i would have
i know too many dirt bags for that not
to be a case somebody's got to keep 200
feet away even if it was filed because
it's like hey we filed it because
there's some you know what i mean even
you know just playing uh playing yeah
setting you up for something else yes
yeah i don't know uh i'm sh i would have
to assume
yeah yeah we got to have friends who
can't get within 100 feet of skrillex or
something
[Applause]
i'm banned skrillex the juggalos
turns out i see we can't take a joke
all right then we'll get out of here on
this one this one's from jared uh is it
trap
this is more of a debate is it trash to
call ramen noodles oodles of noodles i
always thought that that was a brand i
feel like i don't know let me look we
used to call it the noodles i think
cause oodles of noodles was a brand was
it
yeah that came with a cup
but there was that's cuppa noodles
but there that i think that was also
oodles yeah oodles noodles tv commercial
1979. oh what are oodles of noodles
ramen noodles packed with a variety of
seasonings sold by nissan food nissan
yeah yeah that's we're top ramen that's
how we operate we were always top ramen
people chicken flavors we were i didn't
have it so i went to college oh my we
were my brother loved that [ __ ] oh yeah
we used to get creative with it too chop
up hamburger
chop up not put the seasoning in chop up
hamburger and put ketchup in it and a
little bit of uh uh what's it called a
one it's nice try it at home don't
nice cold glass of milk if you do don't
tag me chop up a hamburger saute it in a
little a1 put a little bit of ketchup
with the noodles
clean living oh no that's it i'm out
that's that's that's a very tough look
literally just made my blood run cold
gang this has been a family episode
we love you kippy what do you got for
him uh guys as uh at cameron comedy on
all social media i'm almost at ten
thousand on instagram let's [ __ ] we all
are let's [ __ ] get some a little
closer tomorrow just get the [ __ ]
numbers up you know what i mean uh come
to a live show get some merch [ __ ]
tell a friend
don't i don't care we're just [ __ ]
happy listen we [ __ ] love you guys we
love you thank you so much we appreciate
all the support and we'll see you next
week
peace